I don't know is it confusing is it
simple the dog didn't eat the hair how
do you know it was a for the dog that
hair was a toy the hair wasn't food
little mama's mama is saying that thanks
for giving me time to think of what I
was gonna say yes I'm saying she's
saying that the package never arrived
just 6 cute accusing the dog of eating
it is like what that's why it didn't get
there oh I thought the defendant is a
huge problem in this country who is it
right wait so like yeah I really
couldn't tie the difference between the
regular on this dog owner was saying oh
my dog didn't eat the hair that's and so
I'm on Team dog didn't eat the hair and
so I'm on Team dog owner yeah okay do we
give the full 25 so the so who won so
well no like lo what mama won but that
means the defendant won
I don't approve little mamas owner
letting her letting us take little mom
yeah this is low mom is a speedy the
verdicts raised oh babe in a kidnapped
environment
[Music]